after two years of intense negotiations
a two-hour flight from Tehran to Doha
has brought an end to an ordeal for five
imprisoned Americans the second year of
those negotiations saw Cattery mediators
shuttling between hotels and Doha at no
point did the American and Iranian
parties meet face to face
the freed prisoners include U.S Iranian
dual National cemack namazi and image as
well as environmentalist Murat tabas
they had been accused of spying and held
for several years in Tehran they were
released as part of a prisoner swap deal
that included five Iranians also
released from U.S custody
the deal was carefully orchestrated and
began with six billion dollars of funds
of Frozen Iranian oil money initially
seized in South Korea being sent to
Switzerland and then to Doha the Iranian
foreign Ministry confirmed that
transaction
in the framework of our active foreign
policy we have unlocked our frozen
assets in South Korea today God willing
These funds will be in the hands of our
government and people and this
government will spend it accordingly to
the needs of the people
it was a short walk from that plane to
the terminal building but it's not quite
over for them yet they've been met by a
Qatari delegation the prisoners have
been met now by the U.S embassy and
members of the state department they'll
want to get them to the United States as
quickly as possible where they'll be
given a medical evaluation and a
security debriefing
the former Cattery ambassador to the UN
said that this was a good deal for all
it was the address to the two parties of
the uh gold offices of Qatar that led to
such ending
as a matter of fact you know for the
past two two years we've been observing
Qatar officials moving back and forth
between Tehran and Washington DC and
such outcome is good for both countries
especially that people who are you know
happen to be a prisoners and their
families and it's also good for our
region because the more we
thoughtful problem or a problem solved
around us the more our region become
more stable there was a visible sense of
relief as the freed prisoners boarded
the flight out of Tehran on Monday for
Qatar this has been a successful outcome
to a very difficult negotiation process
but this is far from over for the
Iranians and Americans who remain at
odds over several issues including
Iran's nuclear energy program an issue
such as that will require both sides to
sit down and talk face to face Imran
Khan Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera